From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Today is Sunday, June 26, 2016. This is David Klein from the History Department at Virginia Tech,
and, uh, recording an interview for the Civil Rights History Project of the Southern Oral History Program of UNC University of North Carolina.
Also the Library of Congress, and we have Guha Shankar with us today. And also the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Behind the camera today we have John Bishop of Media Generation and UCLA, and we have a guest with us who we are quite honored to be visiting today in El Monte California, Gloria Arellanes.
And if I could ask you this is the one time I will coach you at all if you could introduce yourself for the camera. A full sentence, my name is, and where and when you are born.
My name is Gloria Arellanes. I live in El Monte California, I have lived here all my life. I was born in 1946, making me a 70-year-old. And that's quite an accomplishment in my family.
People don't live too long. But I went to school here, I went to East Los Angeles College briefly. It was not interesting, one some life experience.
So I know that we are in a house that your parents bought, and I wonder if you could tell us a little bit about, even before them, about your people and the history in this area.
I am a Tongva elder, and my ancestors had this area, this was the village known as Houtgna, the place of the Willow.
And there aren't too many Willows, there are more near where the original mission site was. There are still a lot of Willows out there.
Of course development has removed everything that was natural in this area. But we had lived here, well now it's 65 years, I've lived here, and my parents were living in East Los Angeles.
I came out of the Maravilla projects, and my grandmother lived on a methamic endosure. So my father had a little wrought-iron shop right there in East Los Angeles across the street. So we were always right there in that area.
And on his GI benefits he came out here to El Monte to get this home, and went through the process, so that I scroll and everything, everything was approved, and on the last day my mother came to sign.
And my father was very fair skinned, very light, hazel eyes. My mother was very native looking, she was native, she was a Tongva, very dark, black hair.
So they had not seen my mother, but we're dealing with my father. Arellanes's was not, and still isn't a very common name. So they didn't know what they thought he was Greek I think.
And when they saw my mother they said, oh no, no, no, we have to take this house back. And my father went into a rage, he was a businessman, he was a rhodor and person.
So he knew how to run a business. He was self-employed, and he says, I will sue you. You have my money, you have put me through escrow, you are not taking this house back.
And so they couldn't do anything about it. So we moved into this house. And as I grew up my mother telling me that there was problems buying the house, they didn't want to sell the house, but she didn't give me the reasons why.
So about three years ago I became involved with these El Monte, South El Monte, Arts Pasi group out here. They wanted to do an interview with me. Well, again, Man Road in Essay, and they wanted to meet me and I spoke to a group here.
And it was then after I started reading some of their articles about El Monte that I found out you could not buy homes or sell homes to Mexicans and Asian people.
And that was the reason why they tried to take the house back. And I was really shocked. I didn't know. And other people say, oh yeah, that was really common.
And I just had no idea, you know, because I wasn't as a child, I was never raised with any kind of racism or forms of hatred of people, because of their color or their looks.
And so to find that out was very shocking for me, even though afterwards when I got, when we lived here in El Monte, it was predominantly an Anglo community.
I did experience a lot of racism. And into high school we had race riots. We're only the Chicanos would be arrested. And we were made fun of, you know, we were embarrassed to eat our bean burritos.
You know, and people kill for bean burritos now. You know, they love them. You know, but that's how racist it was. And when we walked down the street coming from high school, we stayed in large groups because we were yelled at and things were thrown at us.
And, you know, like I say, we had fights in the high school.
So how did your parents identify and what did they teach you about identity?
They confused me. They confused me because my dad would say, your Chicano. And I would say, no, dad, I'm American. School tells me I'm American. No, your Chicano. And I would, wow, dad, I'm American. And, you know, he says, no, your Chicano.
So it was very confusing as a child. And then as I got a little older, I had gone to see one of my mother's cousins. And she had all this family genealogy because I had heard we were native.
But nobody would talk to me about it. And so she showed me genealogy. She showed me photos. I have an uncle who wrote books in the 20s and gave a lot of family history.
She even put a rice pudding recipe in his book. And he was a horseman. So he eventually went up to Bakersfield. And he said a lot of the families from here to get away from the mission went to Bakersfield. And he was considered a vaquero, an Indian vaquero.
And his names were always vaquero about vaquero. And when I tell my mother this, she goes, don't listen to her.
She don't listen to anything she tells you. You are Mexican. Don't ever say you're an Indian. And it was so confusing. And I go, why would she do that? She goes, just don't listen to her.
Well, as an adult and doing my own genealogy, I found out I was Tongva or Gabrielino as some people refer to us from the San Gabriel Mission, from this area. We have always lived here. My mother's family came from the Alhambra, California area, Pasadena Alhambra, California area.
And she carried what we call cultural trauma because they were punished for being Indian. When the Spaniards came in the 1800s, they put them to work in the missions and they separated the families because the men didn't want to come in. So just the women and children were forced to come in.
And they were not able to pray in the manner that they're used to praying, dressed as they wish to dress or accustomed to dressing. Speak their language, dance, ceremonies, everything was taken away from us. And women wore tree bark skirts.
Okay, we have beautiful climate in California until climate change, destroyed it. But we didn't have to dress from neck to the bottom of your feet. This is what the Spanish and the missions did to us. They wouldn't let us dress in our customary way.
And therefore we had to change the way we were. And we had to serve them, take care of their children. We were their nannies, I guess. And history always put us as the romantic missions. It was torture for us.
People died in huge amounts of disease. You can go to the mission, they have mass burials. Everybody asks it's individual plaques and so forth, Tommy Temple and so forth. But you look thousands of Indians were buried here. They died of measles or whatever disease it was, chicken pox.
So it destroyed, it almost destroyed us in history did say we no longer exist, we were extinct and that's not true. And it seems like every day I meet, not every day, but when I go to some kind of a gathering, I'll meet somebody new that who has just discovered they are Tongva.
You know, it's very exciting, you know, so we have a fairly large tribe now and we've been able to get some language back. We've gone back to our regular regalia. And we're learning language. We'll never have a full language. There are no fluent speakers, but we can say, you know, bits and pieces because John Peabody Harrington recorded a lot of that. So it was confusing growing up.
And how about about your father's insistence on, I mean, your father had a strong Chicano identity and you carried that into high school?
Yes, into high school. And it's kind of interesting because he was such a conservative man, him and I clashed ideologically.
He just, it was funny because that's what he identified me, Chicano. And yet he was a businessman.
He belonged to the Arts Club, the Mason's Club, you know, and he didn't, I didn't see him as a Chicano.
You know, it's kind of interesting. And my mother just kind of went along, you know, with things. She never, you know, seemed to say, you should be this, you should be that.
You know, my father was more wanting me to go, he wanted to see me be successful, but yet he wanted me to be married and have children, you know.
It was very confusing for me sometimes for my dad. And he was hard to communicate with because he was raised, his father died at a young age and he had to take care of a large family.
And I think that made him very hard sometimes, you know, he wasn't an affectionate man, he wasn't, you know, like my mother, my mother was completely opposite.
She was, you know, up into her death, she was my best friend, you know. But it was hard growing up with my dad, you know.
Although I know he loved me, he provided for us very well, you know, we were never hungry, you know, we weren't, I mean, this isn't a, you know, a castle here, you know, but it was a home.
And he didn't, well, he brought you all out here, exactly, better than that.
And he wouldn't let us speak Spanish, I had a brother, he would not let us speak Spanish because he didn't want us to have an accent.
So had he lived long enough, he would have known that's a benefit to be bilingual, trilingual, you know.
But that didn't happen and tells you kind of the thinking of those days, you know, in his family, his family was traveling musicians from Chihuahua.
And they traveled on a, a, a, a donkey, okay. And they were musicians and one of my uncles was, I mean, the house they lived in, it was, it was a castle.
And they had a big house in East LA and they had an organ with all the pedals on the floor and a whole pipe room.
That's how big that house was and we weren't allowed to touch that, but Gloria used to like to go and they push all the buttons and pump everything and then I hear.
Here came Grandma, you know, and I'd run, you know, and I'd go to that, they said, do not go in that pipe room.
And it was dark and I used to just open the door and then push the pipes just to hear the sound. It was quite amazing.
And it was such a, a dinosaur, nobody would even take it when she passed away and they were cleaning out the house.
And there was a baby grand piano in there and those square kind of guitars. I think they're Japanese.
You know, some kind of a string instrument. Yeah, that was my uncle. He was a musician.
So what about the sort of first stirrings of the kind of activist, Chicana identity for yourself?
For myself, that was in high school because of the racism that we're exposed to. We kind of stuck together, you know, for protection.
And one of the parents, she actually lived around the corner. She would say, you know, come over to my house.
You can, you know, let's start a youth council, let's do things. And we, I have pictures in my collection.
No, those are not in my collection. Those are my personal things. But where we were doing the stroll, you know, the dance,
she would let us play music and, you know, hang out there. And that would take us to do community type activities.
And I think that's where it started for me. And then the high school eventually there was a counselor who took interest with us because of all the fighting that was going on.
And the riots, I call them race riots, we went on and only Chicanos were being arrested.
You know, sorry, I went blank.
In the high school. Yeah. The counselor who took interest. Yeah.
Yeah, this was, he, counselor Jack Barton took interest in us. So he let us have meetings and we talked about these things.
And we went in the surfers who were, that's who were fighting. Sounds kind of letting out, you know.
But in conversations, it started as screaming at each other's and the hatred was coming out.
And then afterwards you just kind of, you lose your wind. And you realize that's just a human being sitting over there.
And, you know, it's like, and then the talk begins. And then we did several of those.
And we went to the junior high schools to get the young kids involved to not, you know, come into the high school.
Because when you go from junior high school to high school, it's a whole different population. It's larger. It's, you know, many backgrounds. And it was difficult.
You know, and I remember in schools, even the teachers, you know, when you raise your hand, you're all enthusiastic. I know the answer. And they don't, they look at you and they just, you know,
you know, that teacher does not like you. I didn't know it was because of who or what I looked like. You know, those are things I learned later.
You know, plus I'm five foot eight. I'm very big-boned. I'm, I would almost 300 pounds when I was in high school. So I was bullied a lot.
And that made me kind of tough, you know, because I, all through elementary school, I was harassed and made fun of.
And I think I just reached a point in my 20s when I said, you know, I don't care what you think about this. If you can't see this and you can't see this, I don't have time for you.
But I had to fight my way through and people were afraid of me because I was so big or, you know, just ridiculed me. And it just makes you a fighter.
And I think that's why it was easy for me to go into the Chicano community in the movement area, you know, because I was a fighter already.
You know, I was very mouthy. Never had to hit anybody. Never because people were afraid of me, you know, I'll get your move.
You just stand up. Yeah. And I did. Oh, I'm a, I'm a, I love body language. And I did use my size to intimidate. Honest truth.
Okay, we're back again. We were talking about high school and we were talking about your, your size and these questions and being a fighter inside the German person.
And how that may have benefited you or drawn you in to the more militant side. And so if you could take us from high school and into your, the years just after that.
And into the movement.
One of my first jobs was the White Tap Program Youth Temporary Employment Project.
And I worked over in South El Monte and worked with young people and, you know, did the activities that we did. And then from there, I worked a regular employment job, which was horrible, a factory with the satin-covered Christmas-tree ornaments and artificial flower arrangements.
And then somehow I got over to East El A in the anti-poverty program, neighborhood adult participation project, NAPP.
And the other thing I was doing was cruising with Whittier Boulevard socially for our social activities. We'd load up from El Monte and we'd go down the boulevard and just have a ball.
And I don't know how I met these people. And I don't remember who it was that I met. But they invited me to go to a coffee house on Olympic boulevard.
And we were like, well, why should we go there? Oh, you'll really like it. It's really nice to go and just sit down and talk to people.
So we went and this was a La Piranya Coffee House. And it was completely dark. And so we're like, I don't get it.
Well, somebody came out and said, oh, come in, come in, be comfortable. And normally somebody should be afraid to go into a dark place.
And we were in this threatened as people are crazy now, a little bit off the off balance that, you know, I wouldn't dare walk into a dark building now.
But it's, you know, young people, hey, let's go party, you know. And we went in and people were in there, but they were in the dark. And then it didn't take long to see why there was a sheriff going by with their flood lights shining in the window.
And you know, and people would just kind of sit back. And it was at a time when the Brown Berets were being formed. And it was a young to come for community action group.
And they did have a legitimate coffee house. And it was just going out of business because of the harassment. And it because it drew young people basically.
So talking to these young people, I was hearing things that I had never, ever heard. And so they said, would you like to join us? And they weren't brown buries yet.
And they just said, would you like to join us? I go, you know, let me learn a little bit more. I don't quite understand everything.
And I was like, three times to go back and say, okay, I'm ready. And from there, I mean, it was brown buries.
Good group of young people who wanted to make changes, who were tired of the police brutality.
And I'm tired of not being able to go to college. We're tired of not getting good jobs, living in poor housing, you know, knowing that people, people around them, their own family, needed health care and didn't have that.
So these are all things that, you know, touch my heart. And, you know, I have passions for, I developed passions at that time, actually. I mean, I was learning. And because here I came from El Monte, and I was in a comfortable home, I had food.
My dad wanted me in college, you know, he was working to put me in college. And I did go right, I went to one semester at East LA College, and I told dad, it's just not for me.
I felt like everything just went over me. And it didn't make sense to me. And I needed to get that life experience in my case.
So that's what I started doing. And from there, you know, it was protesting everything that was unjust. And then learning other groups that were doing the same thing.
In high school, remembering, you know, what happened in the South to the Black people, and the brutality that they were exposed to and, you know, suffered and were killed for.
So what year was it roughly those first meetings at the coffee house?
Oh, in the 60s. Probably middle 60s. I know I'm real mad with dates, but the middle 60s.
I would say that the La Piranya Coffee House coffee house was the birthplace of the Chicano movement. There was nobody else doing that.
There were organizations like, you know, the voter-rights people, you know, things like that. And after, as I know, they were just coming out of the woodwork, just, you know, starting programs and things like that.
But we were not accepted. It was very difficult. When people learned about Brown Berets, you know, it was time went on. They looked at it as militant troublemakers.
Okay. I remember in some of our training, they would say, you know, one of the things that always stay with my entire life is never argue with somebody. It cuts your channel communication.
And that is so true. Once you start arguing, you're yelling about your feelings, you're yelling about your feelings, and nobody's going to come together and understand anything.
So we were told, you know, you're going to come across people they don't like you, and you're just going to have to take it.
And somebody who's already a little pissed off, you know, that's like, you know, you had to bite your tongue.
And I remember we were sent to some gathering that was at UCLA College Stadium, and we were supposed to pass out flyers about the Brown Berets and the event.
And I remember this family, and I gave them a flyer, and the man got it, read it, he crumbled it up, he goes,
she got on us and he threw it at my feet. And I just, that was one of those moments, you know, but I just maintained myself, you know.
So it was hard in the beginning. Young people were very attracted to this kind of movement activity.
Because it reminds me in some ways of, you know, the strategy of non-violence, when you're having to hold yourself back.
Yes. And you talked about being aware of the South and the sit-ins, and was there other ways in which you were all paying attention to other movements?
Sure. There was already UMAs, which United Mexican American Students was already being organized in the colleges.
So there was some movement within the schools, and eventually, you know, we tried to meet with all these different groups.
You know, eventually it became, you know, ex-convicts came out with Lucha, and you know, other groups were forming like the ones in the housing projects La Junta was another group.
You know, but eventually everybody began fighting each other's. You know, my philosophy is better than yours. I don't believe in what you believe in blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And I always tried to this, and it's very me to try and get along with everybody.
And always, even when I worked, would find the most difficult employee that everybody was, it didn't stay away from her.
Oh, she's, oh, I would try to find out what it makes this person tick. And they would be my friend, and people say, how do you do that? And I go, just talk to them.
They're, they're usually in pain, you know, carrying some anger, rolling, you know, scary anger.
But that's always been my kind of what I do, you know, so I got along with everybody. Plus it didn't, it helped to have an uncle who was in the, what they call the Ex-Pintos. They came out of the prisons.
He was in that group, so he told them, that's my niece. Don't mess with her. So I got along with them just fine. You know, and other groups that, that Brownberries are fighting with, I got along fine with them.
You know, where their connections across the lines of race to the Black Panthers were. Absolutely. Yeah, we used to go to us organization every Sunday to their, they would have a gathering. And it was a cultural, and it was beautiful to me to see in their beautiful regalia and doing their dances and songs and speaking their language Swahili.
And they welcomed us with open arms. Black Panthers, it was more than men got involved with the Black Panthers.
You know, we did have during the Watts rebellion a non-aggression coalition pact. In other words, if violence goes down, we don't touch the Chicanos. If violence goes down in the Chicano community, you don't touch the Black people. You know, that was an understanding.
So, you know, I do remember that and I never went to near the meetings, but I was aware of that. And, you know, we just got so involved in the Brownberries with community. And we opened a free clinic eventually. And that was started by David Sanchez, who was the prime minister.
And he was meeting with the physicians for community action and psychologists for community action. They're mostly Anglo and Jewish people. And I had...